[Musique]
Lulu vendait ses toiles Jacob plongé
dans un bistr
ddgûter les
vins moi j'étais fort au Hal et j'ai
j'ai lavé les carreaux pierre ne faisait
rien on s'était fait les poches pour se
payer un vieux taco fleu sur le
capot qui rêvait de Provence et qui
mourut à Fontaine blanc on allumé une
cigarette et tout s'allumé et c'était la
fête le 14 juillet il n'y avait jamais
un copain de trop dans l'équipage
auj il y avait moins de nuit sans
guitare que de jours sans pain on
partageait tout et on nait rien
qu'est-ce qu'on était fou qu'est-ce
qu'on s'en foutait qu'est-ce qu'on était
bien on louait pour des prunes les
quatre murs d'un vieux grenier tout prêt
à
s'écrouler mais pour toute une
fortune on n'aurait pas
déménager on all met une cigarette et
tout s'allumé et c'était la fête le 14
juillet il n'y avait jamais un copain de
trop dans l'équipage
Jojo il y avait moins de nuit sans
guitare que de jours sans pain on
partageait tout et on avait rien
qu'est-ce qu'on était fou qu'est-ce
qu'on s'en foutait qu'est-ce qu'on était
bien ti un ami les voile et j'acé payer
un bistron ù André boit de l'eau je ne
suis plus fort au h Roger inspecte les
impôts pierre cherche du boulot j'ai
changé de guitare mais j'ai gardé qu'un
ma cadeau cette air qui me tient chaud
du fond de la mémoire
celui de l'équipe à
Jojo on alluma une cigarette et tout s'
allumé et c'était la fête le 14 juillet
il n'y avait jamais un copain de trop
dans l'équipe à
Jojo il y avait moins de nuit sans
guitare que de jour sans pain on
partageait tout et on n'avait rien
qu'est-ce qu'on était fou qu'est-ce
qu'on s'en foutait qu'est-ce qu'on était
bien
c'est vrai